so here we are at the Undercity ruins
they are known in game as the ruins of
no Ste that is their kind of in-game
lore name this is just the entrance you
go inside this big Cathedral here and as
we go inside you can actually see some
of the like very intense environmental
work that our environment artists did
all this really pretty scaffolding this
broken-down look there's a lot of this
kind of ruins feel too much of the
structures that are out here in the
desert I'm gonna have to crouch and walk
underneath this and then we are heading
down into the ruins so this is probably
the most difficult of the three caves
and as far as I'm concerned it is
probably the most beautiful of them as
well
huge shut up to our level designers who
did an enormous amount of work making
these things just absolutely
breathtaking to explore the particular
theme here is huge crystalline
structures and then ruins of kind of an
old city that has been built down here
kind of overgrown by the ground as it
swept through and kind of took over
after the place was abandoned you can
see these light shafts actually the pour
through from above we control these by
the day cycle so as it becomes nighttime
these will actually disappear and as the
Sun comes up and brightens everything up
the light shafts come back we've done a
lot of little touches like that to try
and kind of bring life to these these
ruins in a way that is connected to the
outside world and kind of in a way that
we haven't done before so be a little
bit careful they're going to be
creatures in here these caves are not
safe just burn these guys up with a
little bit of flamethrower love I can
also hear a golem coming to life so if
you want to be a little bit careful as
we approach here I'm going to bust out
some heavy weaponry
and even here he is that's a goal so
we're gonna pop some buster grenades on
this guy
Buster grenade is one of the new super
powerful weapons that we've got it is
essentially a normal grenade it blows up
into a bunch of smaller grenades and
there goes the big guy just do we need
to get you some more clothes real quick
so the caves are a great place to start
loading up on some of the kind of more
rare and valuable resources you can see
rocks down here that are these are
obsidian rocks whoops let me get my fire
back in real quick here I obsidian there
are a lot of metal rocks things like
that there is crystal kind of more stuff
that's designed around building up into
the tech tier the the kind of advanced
machinery scorched-earth comes with a
lot of new more high-end gear we've kind
of shown off like the cluster grenades
and we've shown up the rocket launcher
and we've shown off a lot of the stuff
that hello friends we've shown off a lot
of stuff that is kind of built around
the end game we've got the flamethrower
we've got the chainsaw these are all
very very high damaging weapons that are
meant to kind of open up new avenues for
players to kind of destroy one another I
mean that's that's really what it comes
down to is having more power than the
other guy as you can see the flames that
are absolutely burns away just all sorts
of enemies
great for dealing with large groups of
your opponent's dinosaurs they're great
for progressing through kind of more
dangerous areas like these caves the
chainsaw is one of the most powerful
melee weapons that's available the
rocket launcher the friggin homing
missiles are the bee's knees you can
target those things from a huge distance
away and they are not really you can't
just walk out of the way of them anymore
and while they're actually I think the
most expensive piece of ammunition
equipment in the whole game right now
the investment obviously is worth it the
cluster grenades exactly as advertised
it's effectively the power of seven or
eight grenades all in one single
detonate a bull explosive they function
otherwise just like normal grenades they
bounce all that kind of stuff they
really change up kind of the PvP
landscape and the ability to cause
damage to enemy structures the ability
to take down hordes of your opponents in
the late game you're dealing with very
very large very very high hits point
creatures and while dinosaurs will
always kind of be the ideal counter to
dinosaurs we wanted to give players on
foot the ability to kind of hold their
own against massive swarms of creatures
and to fight back against those very
very large targets that previously you
really wouldn't see that kind of an
opportunity rocket launchers were very
very effective but they were kind of the
be-all end-all and now there's more
tools that the players disposal for
dealing with those large Dino armies we
would recommend that anybody who's
interested in playing scorched earth
either make sure that they play it with
a friend who does know the game a little
bit better or that they go ahead and
play the base game get a few levels in
that kind of stuff because of the fact
that this content is more difficult and
it does assume that you know how to
start out but you know how to quickly
build a shelter that you know all the
different resources that you're going to
need and how to get a hold of them it's
a little bit more difficult definitely
all around managing things like your
water and other resources like the
actual food and stuff like that that you
need to stay alive is a difficult task
and it's definitely emphasized in
scorched earth without those kind of
abilities you're going to be
you're gonna kind of be left a little
bit high and dry so here we have the
kind of the big Vista it comes with this
particular cave we have these on all of
the caves kind of a reward for the
player getting down to the main chamber
you can see that we've kind of lit up
the room over there on the far side to
show you where you're headed to we're
gonna go ahead and do the little jumping
puzzle here now so watch your step there
is a gap here and you do have to make
these jumps or you do die we kind of
like to incorporate these kinds of
actual physical gameplay elements rather
than just walk in a line and kill
everything in your path just to kind of
break up the monotony you otherwise run
run run kill kill kill yes we get past
the
hello missiles once we get past that
their head down this way ask some of
this again just absolutely beautiful
environmental huge old chapel kind of
taken over by all these massive crystals
in stone
if we go
I believe there is probably one more
Gollum defending the end of this here so
this here is the artifact room we have
one of these in pretty much all of our
caves they are kind of the reward for
the player who has managed to get to the
deepest part of the cave these artifacts
are incredibly important you need all
three of them as a tribute to be able to
fight the final boss generally we have
something very very very pretty or
somewhat lore related something to kind
of tell the story of the area in these
rooms you can go ahead and grab that
artifact out and at this point we would
go ahead and exit the cave one last
thing I do want to do with you is take
you to show you the boss unfortunately I
have all the artifacts and stuff like
that prepared and here we go we are
transporting to the boss now normally
any dinosaurs any creatures that you
happen to own that are inside this area
and are underneath a certain size will
get teleported with you to the boss
arena you can see it kind of coming in
around us the canyon kind of forming on
the inside of this dome that's
encircling us and then we are teleported
to the boss arena and you can see mr.
Manticore up there on his perch
and now the fight begins
and he is mean and very very powerful
it's not really possible for us to kill
him here but you're free to take some
shots at him until he summons all of his
stuff up
so he was built around the idea of a
team of between four and six people all
with pretty much all endgame here as
well as a group of like probably four to
six absolute max level and game Rex's
the mileage you get will vary in terms
of the other creatures you want to bring
with because on this map especially
endgame Rex's are really really
difficult to get a hold of so if you
come into this fight with anything that
isn't that much power you're gonna have
a harder time for beating the manticore
you get obviously those skin items that
you've seen the shield you can get the
helmet you can get the trophy like the
the head trophy that you saw you get the
flag and at the moment you also get the
prestige of having beaten later on there
will be other rewards that you get for
beating all of the bosses currently
there are just placeholders in which are
those kind of flags but you get those
placeholders are there just until we
have end of the end game
because beating the bosses will be
required for kind of that final in-game
getting access to all of the super like
super care items that are part of tech
tier like the bosses are going to be
very very important in all of that you
can see on the outside here we have
these really really pretty flags these
flags are the new boss flag that you get
for defeating the manticore boss he is
the new boss that comes with scorched
earth if you manage to defeat all of the
caves get the artifacts from inside and
conquer the boss we've got his head
mounted on the wall right here this is
also a trophy that you can get from
defeating him we actually created kind
of a bunch of different kinds of
trophies that are available to players
who defeat the manticore not just these
like cosmetic items but also a number of
skins that you can get for helmets and
shields oh thanks so much for sitting
down and talking with me about scorched
earth and all of the cool new content
that's available and you can pick it up
now on the steam store 20 bucks it's a
ton of new content kind of cool stuff to
see and go pick it up try it out it's
it's really really awesome
you